what are my favorite work life hacks so
I recently did a video about my favorite
YouTube channels and the ones that I
subscribed to there aren't that many the
ones that I kind of watch all the time
and one of my loyal YouTube followers
Neil pol shook wrote in to ask me Evan I
love the Tim Ferriss channel that you
you added what are some of your favorite
work life hacks and that's a that's a
tough question for me because for the
past I don't know ten years I've been
doing a ton of experiments on myself and
my productivity on things that that I
like and don't know what works I'm
constantly changing around my schedule
and the things that I do and I live kind
of a weird lifestyle I guess compared to
most people you know I wear barefoot
shoes I use a stand-up desk I go
snowboard in the middle the afternoon
and we go all over the place I'm in the
office three hours a day from Monday to
Thursday it's kind of uh it's different
I guess and it's come from years of kind
of trial and error wasn't just one day I
woke up and tried to do all these things
all at once I don't use my cell phone my
phone number isn't on my business card
or my website that's another big one
anyway so some of the ones I've had kind
of the biggest impact for me personally
I'm gonna share three of them and
hopefully this helps answer the question
this one made me think Neil it made me
think you making me do some hard work
today
the first one was when I first started
delegating I remember with my first
company my software company I always
kind of had in my head that I had to do
everything myself or my partners would
do it but not the idea of having
somebody come on to help me and the
first person I brought on board was for
one hour a day I couldn't afford to hire
a full-time person and I was growing
increasingly frustrated with all the
repetitive tasks that I had to do and it
was like I can't focus on the bigger
stuff because I'm so crunched down and
doing these stupid things and I felt
like somebody could do this better than
me and my my aha moment I guess came
when I realized that I don't have to
hire somebody full-time which I couldn't
afford I can hire somebody for a little
bit amount of time and it was a guy I
knew his name was Rob first guy hired
and it was for one hour day and I was
doing a bunch of database work that I
hated and I gave it to him and he was
better at it faster at it than me he got
a lot more done in that hour than I
could and it freed up an hour of time
for me to go and do more stuff with my
business and that was just a little
improvement I guess to my life at the
time but it just set me on this course
because now I hate doing things that are
repetitive tasks and as quickly as
possible as soon as I get bored or
something I'm handing it off to someone
else to do or maybe killing a project
but but I am NOT stuck in repetitive
task mode and being held back from doing
things that I need to do to grow my
business and that's just I don't know it
kills your creativity it kills your
productivity when you're stuck doing
repetitive things that you hate over and
over and over again so ever since that
one small event of hiring Rob for one
hour a day I've been looking to make my
workflow easier and more efficient by
hiring people
the second was chunking my time and this
one came to me as a result of reading
the 4-hour workweek and the idea here is
anything that you do multiple times per
week do once per week you do things
multiple times per day do once per day
the first biggest improvement thing was
email I used to be the guy who have
super fast on email answering right away
you know I get that alert when it came
into my Outlook at the time and I would
go and answer it right away and people
would respond how fast I was and it was
great but every time I went to check my
email because something new came in it
distracted me from something else and I
ended up not getting my other tasks done
I would just basically be on email all
day and it just killed my creativity and
my productivity and so what I did was I
said okay I'm gonna do email I started
it twice a day and then I went down to
once a day and now I don't even have a
set time for email I do it when I'm not
doing anything else and just unloading
that was a huge relief for me it freed
up so much of my time cuz think about
when you get interrupted at least for me
it takes to another like half an hour to
get back into the zone I was in and so I
that elimination lets me just focus
hardcore on set tasks and it really
helped me I've applied that chunking to
everything I do in my schedule so I do
my videos on a Wednesday so I I speak
with my media coach Wednesday morning
today's Wednesday
I spoke with genja this morning and then
sit down and do my videos and so I'm
kind of I'm in video mode I'm thinking
video when I'm in the shower I'm
thinking what I'm gonna talk about my
video washing the hair what's gonna
happen my video and I'm ready to do back
to back to back to back to back videos
and it's great because setting up the
video camera and the microphone and
everything getting the questions ready
takes time and so I don't have to do
that each time I do it once per week and
I'm done on Thursdays I do my meetings
and interviews and my radio show and I'm
kind of in that zone that day so I'm not
worried about admin tasks or anything
else related to the business I'm just
meeting people talking to people and
it's easy to go from one meeting to the
next to the next to the next hangout on
Google and whatever it is that I'm doing
again I found before if I had meetings
all over the place
half an hour before meeting I found like
my productivity was was shot like I
can't start something new because I know
I have a meeting coming up in 30 minutes
so I'm just gonna do little tasks right
and I just found that happen too much
but when you have back to back to back
to back meetings it kind of just puts
you in that zone and helps you flow
through without being distracted by
what's happening next and then on Monday
and Tuesday I'll do more of my
solitary work or project work so if I'm
writing my newsletter or writing an
article or doing something that I can
just do by myself
you know maybe I won't shave that day
whatever I feel like doing I'm kind of
in that zone and I find to just send
that my week that way really helps me
and then the third thing that I discover
and this was the hardest one for me to
break I think was was flow and momentum
so one thing I found with my chunk
schedule was like I was getting a lot
more done right by chunking my time and
limiting the email to certain parts of
the day I got so much more done during
the day but then I sometimes found
myself wanting to continue on on
something and having to stop because I
fell outside my chunk so I would chunk
my day into 90-minute segments I found I
would I would work best in Sprint's of
90 minutes then take a break then
something else for 90 minutes and
knowing that I only had 90 minutes kind
of forces me to go crazy fast but I
found just sometimes when I was working
on a project that I wanted more time I
was really feeling this idea I was
really feeling it and so I was in flow
and I found if I came back to it the
next day I feel like what was I thinking
about yesterday what was that project I
was working on I don't I would write
notes I don't remember what they mean
anymore I know if that happens to you
guys it happened to me and so I would
break my chunking schedule only if I was
in the flow and because the stuff that
you create when you're in flow is so
critical so important that's like the
big picture life-changing stuff you have
to keep going on it and you don't want
to fool yourself and say you know I'm in
the flow on these emails this is great
I'm answering everything so quickly
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about the big ideas the things
that will change you and your business
for the better you get those things you
don't wait on them
don't don't wait on it and then you come
back tomorrow and it's it's like the
idea is not quite there anymore take
action right away I learn the rules of
chunking and then and then I know when
to break them with momentum all right so
those are the three things that that in
terms of work life
tax productivity have helped me the most
so again delegating even for one hour a
day and just taking the stuff off your
plate that you don't need to be doing
then chunking your time down so anything
you do multiple times you're doing it
once at a time and just set that time
aside so you can be excellent at it and
then momentum when you're in the flow
when you're feeling the momentum that's
the most important thing that you need
to work work and focus on for that day
and forget everything else that you're
doing because you're gonna you have to
stay in that zone I've created a series
of Zuka guides that go through exactly
how I break down those processes how to
automate eliminate delegate use flow
just from my experience as an
entrepreneur it's basically time
management for entrepreneur and a series
of guides so that could be super helpful
for you but those are my three I guess
most impactful most powerful things I
discovered that shaped how I view the
world as an entrepreneur and how I'm
more productive in my life so thank you
for the great question Neal for those of
you guys watching you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below you
have a question if you want to share a
productivity or life hack that's worked
well for you please leave it in the
comments below and if you want to see
more videos like this you can click on
my face subscribe to the channel and
you'll see more thank you guys so much
and I'll see you soon